Kobe just someone who is a you know
obviously physically to me he's the most
skilled player we've ever seen so he
always had that but then he would try to
just mentally [__] with you you know
grab you lb you do little dirty [__] and
they would never call it because it's
him yeah he would get away with murder
like this is the reaction no I didn't I
had no it was like I was on autopilot my
arms just did it it just happened and
that [__] like you know it was on his
eyelashes and he didn't blink but I
think that changed his impression of me
because as soon as that season ended I
got a phone call from a number I didn't
know I happened to pick it up and it was
him we talked back and forth about you
know they had won the championship that
year and he asked what I was gonna do
the following year and he's just like
you know anyone crazy enough to [__]
with me is crazy enough to play with me
he's like do you want to be a Laker oh
[__] hell [__] yeah you know he
uh [__] invited me to come be a part of
this team and like four days later I was
a Laker so it went from like it went
from uh in moment incident to what
turned up in a short amount of time me
and like a real Brotherhood